welcome back to another Q&A episode of
the stronger by science podcast before
we get into today's questions we do want
to make a big announcement that we're
very excited about as many of you know
we have a monthly research review called
mass where we review the most
interesting exercise and nutrition
studies from the previous month and tell
you how you can use them in your own
training or in training your clients we
know that many of our listeners reside
in spanish-speaking countries and we are
very excited to announce that mass will
now be translated to Spanish starting on
November 1st we will be translating to
issues of mass per month the first will
come out at the beginning of the month
and the second will come out in the
middle of the month and if you want to
subscribe to the Spanish version of mass
the pre-sale for that actually begins
today we have a special presale price
which is the lowest the price will ever
be but it is only good for the first 500
people who subscribe so if you're
interested in subscribing you can go to
tiny dot CC slash Spanish mass to get
all signed up and get locked in at that
pre-sale price now moving on to other
business we've got an excellent Q&A
episode this week in today's episode
Greg and I answer some listener
questions about carbohydrate intake
sodium intake training to improve your
speed or your strength endurance how to
experiment with different training
styles and training variables to find
out what works best for you whether or
not there is a minimum necessary volume
per training session and much more to
finish off the episode Greg and I talked
a little bit about Bayesian statistics
and how to start a fitness career
without a formal academic background in
exercise or nutrition as always thank
you for listening
we hope you enjoy
welcome back to another Q&A episode of
the stronger by science podcast this is
your host Eric Trexler today I'm joined
by a special guest co-host named Greg
knuckles thanks for having me back on so
we've got first question for greg from
jacob kowalski
the question is we always hear people
talking about power strength and
hypertrophy
but for some reason strength endurance
doesn't get any love so what is the best
approach for increasing strength
endurance that is increasing the maximum
reps a person can complete for a given
exercise yeah so some of the examples
that Jacob gives in this question is you
know let's say someone wanted to be able
to do 200 push-ups or 100 pull-ups in a
row or if they wanted to be able to
squat a hundred kilos for a hundred reps
straight so basically just asking how
one would go about training for strength
endurance type goals and so I think the
answer to that question is going to
depend on a few things first is like
what is the weight that you're trying to
do the strength endurance feat with and
how heavy is that relative to your
current max so for example if you want
to be able to benchpress 100 kilos for
20 reps and your current one rep max is
a hundred and ten kilos doing endurance
oriented training isn't going to get you
very far
just because like you know you're trying
to do a bunch of reps with something
that's really close to your max and so
you're probably just too weak so in a
situation like that getting stronger is
probably going to give you the best
return on investment and and that could
apply to a bunch of different things so
it's not just you know like a bench
press or a squat so for example if you
want to be able to do 30 or 40 body but
bodyweight pull-ups but you're like max
weighted pull-up you can only do a
pull-up with like 20 pounds added to
your body like again your bodyweight
even though it's not like an external
resistance is still a relatively large
resistance relative to like what you're
trying to do a strength endurance feat
with so in a lot of cases you are going
to get some bang for your buck just by
you know doing conventional strength
training and getting stronger if you
have two individuals you know you're
trying to do the NFL Combine 225
benchpress for reps one of them has a 1
rep max of 300 pounds and does a lot of
like strength endurance type training
the other one bench is 500 pounds and
does know strength endurance type
training I guarantee the guy who benches
500 pounds is gonna do more reps with
225 so you know whatever you're doing it
has to be like a reasonable percentage
of your maximum force output if your
maximal strength is like probably two to
three times more than whatever you're
trying to do strength endurance stuff
with then maybe like the actual strength
endurance stuff is going to be more of
the limiter but you basically you just
want to make sure that your actual
strength itself isn't the limiter from
the get-go and if it is you know doing
conventional strength training and
trying to get stronger will help next
thing is if you're trying to do some
sort of bodyweight thing so max push-ups
max pull-ups max dips something like
that might not be a bad idea to lose
weight and so you know that's probably
gonna depend on how much you weigh and
in all likelihood like your body
composition so if you're 160 pounds and
lean getting down to 150 may not help
you if that's gonna require a losing
muscle but if you want to do you know a
bunch of pull-ups and you're 220 and 20%
body fat
losing weight is going to help you just
as much as getting stronger well so that
is obviously a consideration not
necessarily a training consideration but
something that will help you out and
then beyond that so let's say your
strength itself isn't a limiter and
let's say you know your body weight or
body composition is in a limiter then in
terms of how you actually approach the
like strength endurance training itself
I think we can probably take
inspiration - how like endurance
athletes train for you know kind of
traditional endurance not strength
endurance so probably some higher
intensity stuff so you know like a
marathon runner is still probably gonna
run like mile repeats or 400 meter
repeats so you know continuing to do
some heavy work trying to get stronger
making sure that what whatever you're
doing is a lower percentage of your 1
rep max continuing to do that it's gonna
help you
and then probably doing some like
quote-unquote race distance type
training is gonna be helpful so you know
let's say you want to squat a hundred
kilos for a hundred reps but currently
you can only do 50 kilos for a hundred
reps something that you know you could
very well do is start by doing sets of
forty or fifty kilos for a hundred reps
and then try to improve on that over
time so you're holding the number of
reps constant based on what your goal is
and then just trying to add weight over
time and then the other thing you can do
is like quote-unquote race pace type
training where you take the weight that
you plan on using and try to add reps to
that over time so again if you want to
squat 100 kilos for a hundred reps just
do max reps at a hundred kilos for you
know three or four sets in the session
and try to improve on that over time and
so if you're doing like the
quote-unquote race distance type
training and quote-unquote race pace
type training eventually you know the
the weight you can do for a hundred reps
should trend up over time and the number
of reps you can do with your target
weight should also trend up over time
and eventually they should meet near
your goal so and then in terms of the
kind of conventional training variables
so like how many sets should you do how
long should you rest between sets and
whatnot
I think the the nsa's recommendation is
for strength endurance stuff to do you
know sets of like fifteen to thirty with
short rest intervals between sets I
don't think that's going to be all that
useful honestly the short rest intervals
at least
because ultimately like performance is
still going to matter here so I think
that kind of more normal rest intervals
like two to three minutes plus would
probably be advisable but you know
obviously still doing really high rep
stuff to improve strength endurance and
then frequency man I think a lot of it's
going to depend how how far you are
along training to your goal so if you're
someone who's only background is in like
conventional heavy lowish volume
strength training you're like you know I
want to squat a hundred kilos for a
hundred reps let's let's just throw a
hundred kilos on the bar and do as many
reps as I can in this workout and see
how it goes
and yet like 50 or 60 reps you're gonna
be [ __ ] tomorrow and you're gonna be
[ __ ] the next day ya plan some
generous rest days following that
introduction for sure yeah so to start
with if you've never done this style of
training before training frequency is
probably gonna take a pretty big hit on
the front end but then you should
probably be able to start ramping that
back up over time to more like
conventional frequencies of like two to
three times per week and then just as a
couple I I guess like theoretical
considerations is it may not be a bad
idea to do like legitimate like local
cardio for whatever muscle you're trying
to Train so when people think cardio
work they think generally you know
running on a treadmill cycling rowing
like full body type stuff which is going
to be really good for building like
global aerobic adaptations which will
improve global aerobic performance but
if it's something where it's going to be
more like targeted muscle group so you
know let's say push-ups or pull-ups you
could do cardio for those individual
muscles where it's probably not going to
give you huge global adaptations but
there are local adaptations to endurance
training so like improved mitochondrial
density and efficiency more
aerobic enzymes etc and so you can get
that with like local endurance training
which may not necessarily be globally
taxing so for example if you wanted to
be able to do just a buttload of
push-ups you could just do dumbbell
press with like ten pound dumbbells or
like fifteen pound dumbbells four sets
of like a hundred plus you know for
durations that would look like kind of a
normal cardio session so just take a
light weight and do it for like the next
twenty or thirty minutes it's not gonna
be particularly fun but that will
probably help with some of the actual
like molecular adaptations that
contribute to strength endurance and
then if it's something again so one of
the examples given was a 100 kilo squat
for 100 reps if you want to do something
like that like Global aerobic endurance
is very likely going to be a limiter as
well so just straight up doing cardio is
gonna help with that like you know doing
cycling or running or whatever probably
isn't going to help you all that much if
your goal relates to like push-ups or
pull-ups but if it's something like
doing a buttload of squats or deadlifts
or say you know doing an ungodly long
farmers walk or something like that that
could very well be limited by like
actual like global aerobic endurance so
just doing straight-up cardio could help
with goals like that how stunt would you
be if you were in the gym and you saw
someone just do like 25 minutes of
dumbbell bench I mean I want to be
stoked for him I mean I'd be shocked I'd
be like oh my god what is happening I
mean am I wrong though no no it's it's a
good idea I just I can't imagine like if
you like you'd be doing this whatever
you're doing right and you're like six
sets and you're like have they stopped I
think they've been benching for 13
minutes dude uh Louie Simmons wrote
about that back in the day not not doing
it for like 25 minutes but like ah man I
don't I don't think he called it the
repetition method like that was
something else he he had some other like
Louie ISM for it
but yet like just telling people like
hey you want to improve your work
capacity for your pressing muscles just
like grab 25 pound dumbbells and press
them for 10 minutes straight or
something like that but yeah I mean I I
think that I think that people lack I
don't know lack some degree of
creativity so you know no one's gonna
bat an eye if they see you rowing for 30
minutes because that's a thing people do
but like how different and obviously
that is going to challenge full-body
stuff more than like dumbbell benches
but that is also going to help improve
like the like local endurance of your
biceps your upper back muscles etc
everything involved in the actual motion
of rowing like it's the exact same thing
doing the same 25 or 30 minutes of
dumbbell bench it's just no one would
think to do it because there's not a
piece of cardio equipment designed for
it
yeah the arm crank or gamma turn ever
caught on at the commercial gym space
thank god those things are horrible yeah
they're the worst
I did have one question for you so you
mentioned the the 20 to 25 bench wraps
test and NFL Combine how do you feel
about the general concept of using that
in the combines I think it's so trash I
do too like a player I really like got
got hurt during the testing for it and I
was like great so now you know how many
times he can bench 220 5 like what did
you plan to do with that you knew his
upper body was strong
you don't really particularly care for
his position but now he's out for like
12 weeks who was it I don't recall I
thought it was I think there was an Ohio
State lineman that that had a pretty
rough PEC strain from him and and kind
of got sidelined for a while I mean the
the person I look at is Christian
McCaffrey he I can't remember which
either he failed at 225 or so he either
failed to get a single rep or he got the
fewest reps of any running back in the
in the draft ever it was one of those
two but he did he did abhorrent ly bad
can't pick him up
yeah a bad prospect and and now I mean
he looks like probably one of the best
five running backs in the league and you
know upper-body strength is probably
going to matter more for like a lineman
or possibly possibly a linebacker than a
running back but it is still going to
matter for a running back like that
that's not a position for it's not it's
not like a punter you know yeah so yeah
I mean I think but I feel like I'd
rather see like a three rep max I'd
rather see a three rep max or like even
like load velocity profiling like that
could potentially be useful so you can
see both like is this guy strong and
against like less resistance are they
super explosive yeah I would love to see
load velocity profiles for like I don't
even care about binge like for squat
though or deadlift I think that would be
super useful
yeah the handful of exercises they use
you're just like man we've learned so
much since we established these like we
could improve them so significantly yeah
I mean I I guess it's just inertia at
this point yeah yeah my favorite though
is the NBA combine also does a bench
press reps test for their combine with
185 yeah in this with 185 and Kevin
Durant is the only player to ever fail
with 185 for a single rep and boy has
that hindered his professional career
well that's why I never took off in the
league yeah I mean it's disgusting
you hate to see it all right so moving
on we have two questions combined the
asker of the first question we are not
saying his name on the air due to
profanity because that's something we
clearly care about on this podcast but
the question is is fast at training and
in parentheses weightlifting ever
beneficial the second question here is
from Nick Nick says I train at 5:00 a.m.
and take a protein shake prior to
training anything else or would you
recommend anything else to do or eat
before working out in a fasted state
yeah so I should Claire
the the first name was it was just very
low humor very toilet humor name
horrible stuff I would have been more
likely to include genuine profanity than
that and what you're gonna see with my
questions for this episode is they're
they're kind of linked I tried to
arrange them in like a step-by-step way
cuz a lot of people had very similar
overlapping questions so let's get
started is fasted weightlifting ever
beneficial we've talked about this
before so I don't want to reiterate
points we've made many times before you
could make an argument in some context
that you would want to do potentially
some low glycogen training or you know
do a training about when your glycogen
storage is low but that's gonna have a
lot more carry over to endurance type
exercise in terms of the adaptations
we're trying to promote with low
glycogen training and it's important to
note that low glycogen training does not
mean fasted training necessarily you
could do it in a fasted state that would
be one way to induce low glycogen but
they're not necessarily the same thing
because honestly if you had an enormous
carbohydrate meal before bed and then
you woke up and worked out in a fasted
state your glycogen still probably is
not quite depleted so that there are
some instances for endurance type
athletes of doing some low glycogen
training specifically I fail to see much
of a crossover that would justify that
type of training strategy for someone
who's purely interested in more lifting
related training so if your goals are
strength and hypertrophy the question
then becomes can you get away with
fasted training not would there be a
benefit of necessarily intentionally
doing it it's not better to do fasted
weightlifting but there are a lot of
people who need to train very early in
the morning and for them sometimes
there's a dilemma where if I try to get
a meal in either have to wake up way
earlier than I want to or I have to eat
in very close proximity to my workout
and then my stomach hurts during my
workout and that actually impairs my
performance so that's kind of the rare
circumstance where
if the if the binary decision is I train
fasted or I have a whole meal and the
whole meal makes me so sick I can't
perform well in that instance it might
make sense to go faster but I think
there's a comfortable middle ground that
you can achieve and that leads me to
question 2 of this kind of question
pairing you know I wake up at 5:00 a.m.
obviously I'm not gonna say well why
don't you wake up at 3:30 make a nice
meal let it digest and then 90 minutes
later you can go to the gym people are
gonna do that so what can what can you
do to try to get some decent pre-workout
nutrition in that scenario what else
would you have besides a protein shake
so on the supplement side of things
there are a couple pre-workout things
that might be helpful generally speaking
this isn't specific to people training
in the fasted State but you know if you
can get a little caffeine dose in maybe
30 to 60 minutes before you know the
brunt of your workout that can give you
a little boost
citrulline malate is usually consumed
about 60 minutes pre so if you just have
a little caffeine and citrulline right
upon waking by the time you get to the
gym and you're really in the groove you
know you've probably got it's probably
in your system enough to do something
for you now the question was if I have a
protein shake you know what else can I
do there before I get into other things
a protein shake is an excellent way to
try to get some nutrition in that
theoretically will be kind of easy to
digest and the reason we would want some
kind of some kind of protein or amino
acids beforehand is so that you know
immediately after the workout you've got
some amino acids in the bloodstream that
can start helping you build some muscle
now some people if they have protein
even if it's a protein shake before
training it can be a little harsh on
their stomach and they struggle to
digest it while they're working out so
if that's you there's a few options on
the table you might find that a
hydrolyzed version of protein is a
little easier for you then a whole
protein they basically hydrolyze some of
those peptide bonds it makes it a little
bit more digestible you could take it a
step further and go with an essential
amino acid mixture which I would
is probably the second best option and
then the third best option which is
better than nothing but probably not
ideal would be it would be to go with
like a branch chain amino acid mixture
so that's how I would kind of rank your
protein options so now outside of
protein what would you want to do I do
think it's a decent idea as long as you
can afford the calories to get some
amount of carbohydrate in that
pre-training meal for most people I say
minimum of like 20 to 40 ish grams of
carbs depending on your body size and
then obviously depending on what exactly
you're doing if you're going for a
3-hour run it's going to be more than
that but if you're going in for a
60-minute bodybuilding workout you can
probably get away with 20 to 40 grams
depending on body size it is interesting
when you look at the pre exercise
carbohydrate literature there are a
couple really interesting things to at
least at least mention so there's some
research showing that even a glucose
mouth rinse has improved some aspects of
performance and most of those studies
are looking at moderate to higher
intensity endurance type training for
the most part and there are some mixed
results some studies show benefits some
studies showed no benefit but it is an
interesting thing that likely currently
the the line of thinking is that there's
some kind of central mechanism that you
have receptors in the oral cavity that
can sense that glucose and they trigger
parts of the brain associated with like
motivation and reward and that that has
a central effect on allowing you to
perform better and exercise there are
studies though that fail to show that I
know tromelin how does he say is his
first name I think it's your Jordan so
he actually sent me a copy of his
dissertation recently and I haven't read
through the whole thing because it's
kind of long I feel like you put a lot
of work into it if I'm being honest it's
really good though no it's it's
exceptional yeah really really good work
but one of his studies was on a glucose
mouth rinse and they found no benefit
either in the fasted or the fed state if
I recall correctly but in any case it's
an
interesting thing about pre-workout
carbohydrate considerations the other
interesting consideration is something
called rebound hypoglycemia and this is
something that I believe the initial
studies that got big were done in the
70s and what they found was they gave
people this pre-workout carbohydrate
about 45 to 60 minutes before the onset
of exercise and what happened was you
know this high carbohydrate meal they
would have blood glucose and insulin
initially go up and then they would
initiate this exercise about 45 to 60
minutes later and they would still have
high blood levels of insulin but then
because of all their muscle activity
there would be an initial drop in
glucose in the blood and what would
happen was they would experience
hypoglycemic symptoms and actually
perform worse but we've done a lot a lot
more research on that concept since and
it seems to vary substantially from
person to person some people are a
little bit sensitive to this
hypoglycemic effect at the onset of
exercise some people really don't seem
to experience it much at all and
generally speaking the studies looking
at pre-workout carb feeding I was gonna
say supplementation but it's not
necessarily supplementation but this pre
exercise carb feeding generally either
has a positive or a neutral effect on
performance across a wide range of
exercise modalities and tasks but if you
if you do seem to get some hypoglycemic
symptoms if you have a high carb meal in
the meal prior to training there are
some strategies that you can use to
combat that and the two strategies that
most people talk about especially asker
you can droop I think that's how he says
the last name but I have no idea but
he's like he's a really really good
sport nutrition researcher who does more
in the endurance realm and does a lot
with carbohydrate his two strategies he
tends to promote the most it seems are
go with a lower GI carb and potentially
even do it in like a mixed meal to kind
of make it a smoother gradual rise in
blood glucose in the insulin response or
you can shift that carbohydrate intake
closer to the workout and that seems to
do the trick as well so those are
considerations to keep in mind with that
pre-workout meal and finally one thing I
haven't mentioned yet is dietary fat
with dietary fat a lot of times because
fat digests so slowly a lot of people if
they have a really high fat meal before
their workouts the digestion is just too
much for their stomach to handle their
stomach hurts they get nauseous during
training they perform really poorly so
if we're talking about a meal being
consumed within that hour before
training I usually tell people to keep
the fat to a minimum I'm really
sensitive in that one time I had back in
my powerlifting days I had a huge meal
of like like I went to a restaurant that
had like buffalo wings which are like
just remarkably fatty and then I tried
to do like a high rep squat work I think
I was doing small out at a time oh god I
think I think I had like a million sets
of 9 that day or something and I just
felt really bad it didn't go well so so
don't do that
some people are totally fine with it but
I would say the average the average
stomach tends to be a little sensitive
to that immediately prior to the workout
so like I said you know there are some
some specific instances where a person
might say based on when I have to wake
up based on how my stomach reacts to
having any food in there I'm just gonna
have to go fasted and it's it's not at
all like oh welp sorry you wasted your
workout you can still do a fine work out
with fasted training I don't think it's
the purely optimal way to go about it
but there are certain cases where it
beats the alternative
of feeling sick your whole workout and
performing poorly but I think generally
speaking there are ways you can
accommodate that that pre exercise
opportunity for nutrient intake to get
you a slightly better outcome than been
training fasted now I agree and one
thing that I would add is like even if
you don't have the time or desire to eat
something before your workout I mean
during your workout itself you could
just sip along on Gatorade instead of
water
and I salute like that that would still
do something for you especially like if
energy levels are potentially an issue
yeah during the workout you could go
with I mean any kind of sports beverage
is going to be you know it's typically a
5 to 8 percent carbohydrate solution
generally speaking and yeah if you want
you could even put some some essential
amino acids in there are some branched
chain amino acids even some people like
to put in hydrolyzed protein during the
workout so so that that's definitely
another another good option ok next
question is for Greg it's from fictional
funkiness could you discuss the
relationship between training frequency
and recoverable volume spreading work
across more session seems as if it would
allow more to be done but is a minimum
volume per session necessary to get
sufficient stimulus yeah so that's a
good question and I think I'm going to
address it in Reverse so the first the
first question I'm going to address is
is there a minimum volume per session
necessary to get in sufficient volume to
have like a meaningful stimulus and as
far as that goes like I don't think we
know for sure at least I'm not aware of
any convincing evidence that volume in a
session can be too low to you know have
some sort of positive beneficial effect
so I mean so there was a the the
meta-analysis that most people refer to
now as it pertains to training volume
and the effects on hypertrophy was by
showing Schoenfeld and colleagues
published I think last year I think it
was 2018 and so it was looking at volume
per week so a number of training sets
per week and that's the one most people
have top of mine that's the one that you
see most people discussing on social
media when the topic of volume comes up
but back in I believe 2010 there was
another meta-analysis like the the prior
one on volume that used to be the one
that everyone would cite by James
Krieger
and I think that may have actually been
his first publication ever he did one on
strength and one on hypertrophy and and
that was back at a time in the industry
when like the the hit crowd like the
high-intensity training one set to
failure is all you need crowd was like
really resurgent within the industry and
so what James did is basically go
through all of the studies looking at
single set versus multi set resistance
training and the effects on hypertrophy
and strength so two different meta
analyses and if for both of them single
set training did have a positive effect
but it wasn't as large as multi set
training so I think for both of those
metas he looked at single set training
and then he looked at like two to four
sets and then he looked at five to six
sets and then there wasn't anything
above six sets that was included in his
meta but anyway so in in both of those
cases single set training did seem to
have positive effects for both strength
and hypertrophy so I don't think I I
don't think we can say that there's like
assuming training is like to failure or
close to failure like just one set is
still probably going to do something
beneficial if that's something that
concerns you though I would say at
minimum if you're doing like three or
four working sets like that's definitely
gonna do something for you maybe like
the optimal volume for you in a session
would be slightly higher than that but
like three or four sets is gonna be a
very very safe level of per session
volume that is going to do something
beneficial for you so then then that
brings up the question of frequency and
whether higher frequencies allow higher
weekly training volumes and just how
that interacts with everything so first
off one thing we need to keep in mind is
that actually no I'm getting ahead of
myself so okay the basic
question of does higher frequency allow
you to tolerate higher weekly volumes I
don't think there's any direct research
looking at that but I think like
logically the answer is absolutely yes
at least to some degree so for example
if we compared you know working out once
per week for a given muscle group to
three times per week or something if you
want to do squats doing five sets of
squats three times a week that's gonna
be kind of hard but it's not gonna be
bad doing 15 hard sets of squats in a
single workout is it gonna [ __ ] suck
I would very much not recommend you do
that and you know you're probably well
past the point of diminishing returns
for what you can get out of that one
workout by the time you get up to 15
sets for a single muscle so I think it's
a little more hazy when you when you
start talking about like higher
frequencies compared to higher yet
frequencies so you know I think if
you're training a particular muscle 3 or
4 times per week you're probably going
to be able to get in more volume than if
you're you know just training that
muscle 1 to 2 times per week but in
terms of like high-quality volume is
like 5 or 6 times per week going to let
you do that much more than 3 or 4 times
per week who knows I think I think that
is a little bit hazy err but yeah
certainly you know having higher higher
frequencies
to a point is going to allow you to do
more high-quality volume per muscle
group one consideration to keep in mind
though is there's some evidence
suggesting that
if you do full-body workouts it may lead
to like a smaller hypertrophic effect
for each of the muscles trained then if
the workout like just focused on that
particular muscle so that's coming from
three studies looking at looking at the
effects of protein supplementation on
muscle protein synthesis of the quads
and so two of them just looked at
different protein doses only doing
training and then the third and most
recent one looked at like a full body
workout but still just looking at muscle
protein synthesis and the quads and the
the volume of training for the quads and
the protein dosages were the same in the
third study is the first two studies but
the the total level of muscle protein
synthesis was like 30% lower give or
take which led the authors to speculate
and then people discussing the study on
social media to speculate that you know
if if you're training more muscle groups
within a given training session like the
overall protein synthetic response for
each muscle group you train maybe a
little bit lower than if it was a
training session just focused on one
single muscle group so like on one hand
we'll higher frequencies allow you to
train with higher weekly volumes yes
absolutely
but then to you know higher frequencies
are going to require you to train more
muscle groups in a particular session
and do more full-body workouts so maybe
like that also requires higher volumes
to have the same effect on a per muscle
per workout basis if that makes sense so
so I think that I think that overall the
research does lean in favor of higher
higher frequencies allowing for higher
volumes and then that higher volume
probably improving hypertrophy and
strength outcomes to some extent but I
don't think the extent to which that
occurs would be as much as one would
assume just looking at the amount of
increase in volume you get so for
example if you can say increase your
weekly volume 50% by increasing your
frequency that's not going to lead to
50% more hypertrophy 50% larger strength
gains it may be better but it may mean
like you know 20% more hypertrophy 20%
larger strength gains so yeah I don't
think that was a particularly well
organized response but I
I think I got everything out there that
I wanted to I think so okay people can
put it back together in whatever order
they choose fair enough
all right so next question for Eric Eric
sugar for performance and Composition
question mark yeah so like I said I
tried to find some related questions
this week and just kind of build them
into like a stepwise thing here so we're
just building on previous answers so the
the the first set of questions was about
you know pre-workout nutrition talked a
little bit about carbohydrate and this
this question specifically about sugar
related to performance and body
composition and you know there's a lot
of bad press for sugar and if you if you
look at the kind of clinical nutrition
research sugar often gets demonized a
bit but you got to remember that the the
purpose for a lot of that research is
generally assuming we're talking to the
general population so relatively low
activity levels and generally speaking I
think it's safe to say that the average
person is now overweight based on BMI I
mean that's got to be correct right I
mean if if the overweight and obesity
together is like 70% of the population
yeah I'm pretty sure that's correct
I I can be I can be your Jamie real
quick and Google that as you talk
what's that reference who's Jamie isn't
she I so I've never listened to an
episode of the Joe Rogan podcast I
haven't either
base based on the memes I've seen
there's someone named Jamie who Joe
always tells people or always tells to
pull things up for him I wonder it in I
always assumed that we Jamie was a woman
but Jamie's a pretty androgynous name so
I shouldn't make that assumption it is
I'm also concerned that we just harpoon
the entire podcast because I don't think
you're allowed to have one if you don't
listen to Joe's right like
that's the podcast is it though I I
thought I thought tim ferriss --is was
the biggest podcast i don't know i don't
have never listened to either i mean
i've listened to like one episode of Tim
Ferriss okay well within this room I
mean the ratings speak for themselves
yeah sure so anyway I will Google the
average BMI in the US as you talk yeah
go ahead and do that so and in any case
a lot of the clinical research and the
messaging related to it that you see is
like assuming that you're relatively
sedentary and not particularly fit and
so yeah like for the general population
that's not actively training frequently
it does make sense to put out kind of
the blanket statement like hey ease up
on the sugar but when when you look at
who in the fitness related world or the
exercise world is consuming a ton of
sugar I've mentioned this on the podcast
before but nobody likes sugar more than
an endurance athlete I mean all the gels
and powders and drinks that they're
putting together are like you look like
you're excited over there
ooh update average BMI is actually worse
than I thought it was Oh was the damage
so average BMI 'zed in the u.s. is
twenty nine point one for men and twenty
nine point six for women ooh I I was
thinking I was thinking it was like in
the twenty seven range yeah I I was
thinking the same move
that's almost obese yes Wow
okay so carry on so in any case yeah it
makes sense that a lot of this public
health messaging is telling everybody
like hey chill with all the sugar guys
but yeah like if you're a relatively
lean very active person we've got all
sorts of examples of these like leaning
fit you know cardiovascular leafit
endurance athletes who have a high level
activity you know fairly optimal body
composition they eat a ton of sugar and
they don't seem to see really any
negative ramifications for that so sugar
in the diet whether you're talking
health or body composition it's it's
generally fine as long as you're not
like super sedentary
as long as you have an appropriate
overall caloric intake and I would say
there is evidence that if you go really
really hard with the fructose intake
that could potentially be deleterious
even at a relatively relatively healthy
body composition status so if you wanted
to if for some reason you had a vendetta
against your liver and you really want
we're just out to destroy it
the way you would put that together is
you go on a very high fat diet with very
very very high fructose intakes and
you'd probably model your drinking
habits after like Hunter s Thompson god
what a legend what a legend but you try
to make sure you're getting plenty of
fructose plenty of fat and plenty of
alcohol but like you know a lot of times
you get this question and it's a person
who has a very healthy body fat level
very active training multiple times a
week and you know they're talking about
is 20 grams of sugar here they're gonna
hurt me the answer is no for your body
composition it's going to be essentially
equivalent to any other carbohydrate
source you've got aside from you know
fiber basically from a health
perspective yeah you don't want to go
way overboard and end up in a spot where
your fructose intake is like a hundred
grams a day which is pretty high and
even if you were there the fructose
issue we're talking about essentially
burdening the liver with this excess of
fructose I mean if you're matching your
activity level and really getting after
it training especially endurance type
training and even with that high
fructose intake you're you're fairly
weight stable at a reasonably low body
fat level you're probably still going to
be like pretty fine I would expect so
generally speaking yeah like it makes
sense to say hey Joe with all the sugar
it it's it's not like doing you any
favors for the most part but there's no
reason for someone who's healthy and fit
and active to be demonizing sugar you
know it's not something that deserves a
great deal of stress or attention we
already talked a little bit about where
you know how sugars might fit into the
pre-workout discussion sugars whenever
you're talking about intra workout
carbohydrate you know most of sports
beverages out there like I said are
gonna be five to eight percent
carbohydrate solutions interesting thing
is they often have a ratio of glucose /
maltodextrin to fructose and it's
usually a ratio of like two to one or
three to one and the reason for that is
because glucose and maltodextrin use
different transporters in the gut than
fructose does so if you were if you were
like doing intra worked out carbohydrate
feeding to try to really maximize
carbohydrate uptake that's why you would
utilize a split in that 2 to 1 or 3 to 1
proportion now for ever I can say for
everyone in this room that's not
important like when we're training we're
not worried about like how am i
absolutely maximizing gut glucose uptake
a gut carbohydrate uptake per unit of
time yeah that's if you're like you know
20 miles deep in a marathon and you're
about to bonk oh and and also shout out
to your and again I think it was his
research that found that the like adding
some some fruit some fructose into the
mix did improve total carbohydrate
uptake versus just glucose that's very
believable his lab does some really cool
stuff I mean I know maybe that had been
observed before but I know that his so I
know he's published research on it and
it's his name that I see attached to
that the most frequently I'm pretty sure
I learned about it as an undergrad so I
think it's been out there but but I I'm
sure they've added a great deal to that
picture I would imagine that their lab
does a lot of really good sport
nutrition stuff now another place where
sugar comes into play you know it is a
rapidly digestible card that would make
sense for pre-workout applications
certainly for intro workout post-workout
sometimes people get really into sugar
because they're like I need to get all
that glucose and right now to replenish
glycogen usually glycogen replenishment
is not going to be a huge deal for the
typical lifter or glycogen replenishment
did I say depletion I met replenishment
but so what we see is that glycogen
replenishment yes there is a brief
window in the I don't know 30 60 90
minutes after a workout probably where
you still you still have a lot of glute
for translocation so when a muscle and
this happens in a localized manner so
whatever muscles were contracting during
the workout it's not just like every
muscle in your body
but after muscles are contracting during
a workout the glute for
transporters they translocate closer to
the surface of the muscle they help let
carbohydrate into the muscle to help
facilitate glycogen replenishment yes
there is a brief window where that
translocation is amplified after a
workout but you know the times where we
really need to utilize that and swoop in
and really prioritize a rapid influx of
carbohydrate after a workout it's
usually if you're doing multiple
glycogen depleting ballets within a 24
hour period what we find is that if
you're not on a super carbon stricted
diet the carbs you're eating not just
after the workout but the meal after
that the meal after that meal after that
generally speaking you're gonna have
pretty sufficient glycogen replenishment
in the 24 hours after your exercise bout
when it comes to the localized muscle
replenishment and the same goes for the
liver you're going to replenish that
over the next 24 hours but if you are a
person who's in one of those
circumstances where you have multiple
strenuous bouts within a 24 hour period
and there are plenty of applications for
that then absolutely it would make sense
to prioritize carbohydrate intake
immediately after those intermittent
bouts and certainly sugar is going to be
a rapid way to to facilitate that uptake
so you know the carbohydrate sport
nutrition relationship when it comes to
pre intra and post-workout nutrition
there are a lot of circumstances to
consider
you know it really is very contextual
but I think it's it's certainly
overstated when you're you know a
healthy fit active person when when you
see all the public health messaging
about getting your sugar as low as it
can possibly be
I think contextually it makes a lot less
sense when you're in that position of
being really active really fit and
looking at it from a sport nutrition
perspective I think that's about all I
have to say oh the other thing I want to
say about sugar if you're on relatively
low calories or a low carbohydrate diet
something that you would theoretically
look out for is if all your carbs are
coming from like gummy worms it is
possible that you're eating too much
sugar e foods not because the sugar
itself is too high but because you're
displacing other good carbohydrate
sources in the diet so you could be
limiting your ability to take in
sufficient fiber a variety of
micronutrients that we find in different
carbohydrate containing fruits and
vegetables and grain products so there
are extreme circumstances where you
might find someone who it's like listen
man you shouldn't have 40% of your carbs
coming from skittles put the skittles
down eat something that is a non candy
carbohydrate source so you do find that
but not often not often okay this is a
quick question short simple to the point
Greg best ways to improve speed with
weights etc question mark hell yeah all
right so the answer to this question
much like the strength endurance
question depends to some degree on what
you mean by weights so are you talking
about speed with a fixed load so just
you know straight up how fast can you
lift 100 kilos or is it like a given
submaximal percentage of your 1 rep max
so how fast can you move 60 % 1rm if
it's the first one if it's how fast you
can move like a fixed
then there are two things you would want
to do one is get stronger because then
whatever the absolute load is it becomes
a lower percentage of your 1 rep max you
will be able to accelerate it to a
greater degree reach higher velocities
it's good stuff and then the other thing
you would want to do is trade train like
the other end of the force velocity
relationship and do very high velocity
over speed type stuff so maybe that
would be like weighted jump squats or if
it's a bench press like medicine ball
throws so just something that's
considerably lighter that you can move
way way faster than whatever the target
resistance is that you are trying to
lift so that's going to pull up on one
side of the force philosophy curve it's
going to pull like up and out on the
other side of the force velocity curve
and so then at any absolute load you
should then be able to move it at a
faster velocity including whatever the
absolute load is that you are interested
in if it's the second so you know you
want to improve the speed at which you
can move you know 70% of 1rm independent
of what your 1rm is then it's just the
second part of that answer so you have
your force velocity curve you want to
pull out on the low load high velocity
end that's going to increase the
velocity at which you can move any given
submalar m so again just lighter
training super explosive stuff what
would often be considered like over
speed type training using a motor
pattern that is the same as are very
similar to the motor pattern you're
trying to improve velocity with and
that's it
short and sweet very nice all right so
next question are actually two questions
for Eric one is from Alex D which is
does the split of carbs and fat in a day
really matter for hypertrophy or fat
loss as long as you hit your calorie
goal get enough
protein and eat carbs before a workout
and the second question from you have
here someone else is true did you just
not get their name or was was this was
this another profanity situation no I
think this was before we created our new
okay question portal so it was just like
anonymous I well I just don't know where
the hell it came from fair enough
all right so the second question from
someone else unknown person but not Alex
T is what effect does high-carb have
versus high fat on hypertrophy
strength and body composition I think
this might have been from someone on
Twitter gave us a list of like 20
questions oh yeah this might have been
from that list that we chopped up yeah I
was like I see 81 something something
yeah I remember that yeah I I think
that's the case okay so this concludes
my long stretch of carbohydrate
questions for it today a lot of people
had a lot of questions about carbs so
these are essentially the same question
right so basically you've got some carbs
you got some fats what's the deal for
someone who's interested in strength
hypertrophy and body composition now the
ratio of carbs to fat in the diet really
does not have to be super specific if
you look at the more clinically-oriented
nutrition literature you see that
whether we're trying to help people lose
weight with a low-carb diet or a low-fat
diet
generally speaking the outcomes appear
to be pretty similar you could make an
argument that some people do better with
one or the other whether that's due to
preference or whether that's due to
insulin sensitivity but as a broad
statement they are both very viable
strategies when it comes to losing
weight and it goes the same way in the
other direction you can absolutely have
a successful successful stretch of
training when you're in a caloric
surplus whether you're getting a lot of
your extra calories from fat or
carbohydrate but that does
I don't have a preference when it comes
to how I approach things for myself or
for my clients so first things first the
most important thing is making sure your
overall calorie intake is appropriate
for your goal whether that's to lose
weight gain weight gain muscle strength
etc the second thing you got to do is
make sure you have adequate protein
intake and at least a bare minimum fat
intake so protein you're usually going
to put it somewhere between like 1.6 to
2.2 grams per kilogram body mass
assuming that we're you know in a you
caloric or even in you know if we're at
energy maintenance or or in positive
energy balance you might go a little
higher than that if you're in a negative
energy balance and then when it comes to
your minimum fat intake I would say for
most people you rarely rarely want to
get below 0.6 grams per kilogram now
once those minimum needs are met you've
got enough protein and enough fat to get
the job done where you get the rest of
your calories is really there's a lot of
freedom and flexibility there but I
generally tend to lean on the in in the
direction of higher carb and lower fat
intakes now the reason I do that and the
question mentioned like as long as I
have carbs before a workout am I good
but I do want to reiterate that like
carb intake isn't as simple as just like
well you put it in right before the
workout you use it and then you're good
you really do want to look at it as kind
of an around-the-clock contribution to
topping off liver glycogen and localized
muscle glycogen it's not just the
pre-workout meal that matters there so
here's the thing if we leaned toward a
lower carb approach and we potentially
are in a carb depleted state or a
glycogen depleted state first of all it
feels bad people don't like to feel bad
second of all point number two there are
studies showing that if we
experimentally induce glycogen depletion
and then take then test strength
endurance strength endurance is impaired
by having low muscle glycogen status and
that shouldn't be particularly
surprising one instance of that
is a study by laborat Leverett and
Abernathy but there there are quite a
few out there showing that generally
speaking if you're interested in
performing well in the in the gym you
don't want to enter the gym in a
glycogen depleted State there's also
some very cool mechanistic research by
Orton Vlad and colleagues where they've
looked over several studies at something
we've mentioned on the podcast before
but localized glycogen depletion near
the sarcoplasmic reticulum and what that
does is reduces calcium output from the
sarcoplasmic reticulum which reduces
force production so obviously if you're
in the lifting business reduce force
production is not of interest to you
it's not a good thing and so what's
important about that is that they they
weren't necessarily looking at absolute
complete glycogen depletion what we find
is that in the early stages where you
start beginning deplete beginning to
deplete glycogen some of those localized
areas of storage near the sarcoplasmic
reticulum seem to be preferentially
depleted first or at least early in the
process so generally speaking being
glycogen depleted is unfavorable so it
makes sense that you would lean toward a
relatively generous carb intake to make
sure that you're minimizing the risk of
that when we look at the research
pertaining to people that are cutting
there are some reason like losing weight
there are some reasons to to suggest
that carbs are pretty solid
there was a study by Mase to and
colleagues and bodybuilders where they
found that insulin and igf-1 correlated
with the retention of lean mass
observational small sample limited
ability to infer causation but generally
speaking we would see insulin and igf-1
typically correlated with a relatively
high carbohydrate intake in the diet
were those were those natural
bodybuilders I believe they were okay so
one of the big confounding things that I
always bring up with that study is the
insulin and igf-1 were also correlated
with I believe fat mass retention so
part of me wonders is maybe it wasn't
dietary carbohydrate maybe those people
didn't
get quite as lean mm-hm and that's what
we're really seeing is that they
maintain more lean mass because I didn't
get quite as lean
I gotcha so it's possible but in any
case the the reason I asked if they were
natural body builders is I was like well
maybe during their bulk they did more
Humalog than the other guys and had some
like lasting insulin sensitivity effects
from that but yeah and I'm pretty sure
they were natural there's also a study
by I think it was Andrew Chappell and
colleagues where I don't know if he
pronounces his name that way I've
emailed them several times but it
doesn't help you pronounce things any
better but but they did find that having
a higher off-season carbon take
correlated with better outcomes again
statistically the the tool the tool kits
limited in that type of design but
generally speaking it looks to be like
having a higher carbon take is probably
gonna have a neutral to positive effect
in those circumstances we also know with
a variety of experimental outcomes that
leptin is quite responsive to
carbohydrate intake which is one of the
reasons when during a cut when we're
worried about trying to do what little
we can to try to support reasonably
decent leptin levels I do like to try to
sneak as much carbohydrate into the diet
as I can get away with now when bulking
carbs are also pretty solid oh I should
also mention that leptin is quite
responsive to carbohydrate intake well I
don't want to skip ahead so like I said
carbs are pretty good when bulking we we
tend to find that de novo lipogenesis
it's pretty uncommon in practice so de
novo lipogenesis is basically taken in a
bunch of carbs you always hear people
say oh you eat a bunch of carbs you're
gonna turn them into fat that doesn't
really happen that much in human beings
what's more likely is you eat a bunch of
carbs you'll probably burn a lot more
carbs at rest and during exercise and
you'll just shift your substrate
utilization to a more carb heavy
oxidation level you'll oxidize a lot
more carbohydrate than fat at rest
usually your body would prefer to just
shift to being more energetically
reliant on carbohydrate than to turn it
into fat and then store it so what we
see
when we give people really high intakes
of carbohydrate we do tend to see that
total energy expenditure goes up a
little bit especially if you're
comparing that to over feeding them with
a similar amount of fat and so what that
translates to in practice is something
I've observed I believe you've observed
it as well but when someone is trying to
bulk up and have a particularly lean
bulk a lot of times I'll try to keep the
fat relatively low and push the
carbohydrate as high as I can get and
first of all people end up being able to
consume a higher total calorie intake
than they probably thought they could
get away with even just to try like
maintain their their normal weight but
as you start bumping it up high enough
to get them to actually gain weight I'd
have observed some pretty pretty lean
gains when pushing people on a high carb
low fat diet and you've seen that before
right yeah so there's there's only one
study I'm aware of like a longitudinal
study looking at this and I believe it
was only published in Portuguese and I
don't think it's been published in
english-language journal so I came
across it on the websites up versity and
so I'm I'm hoping that they like
translated it and interpreted it
correctly but I've pulled up the full
text and like looked at the graphs and
like numbers are the same so hopefully I
can get used Arabic numerals yeah so
hopefully hopefully I can get what I
need out of like the tables and figures
but so essentially in that paper what
they did is they had two overfeeding
groups and both of them would would be
what would typically be considered
pretty high carb but one of them had a
four to one carbohydrate to fat ratio
and the other one had a eight to one
carbohydrate to fat ratio and I want to
say that total calories were either the
same or pretty close but basically what
it worked out to is like one group a
pretty low fat like 60 to 80 grams per
day give or take and the other group ate
super low fat so like
20 to 30 grams per day or something like
that like super super low and in that
study the eight to one carbohydrate to
fat group gained I believe more weight
but also like a much much greater
proportion of lean mass to fat mass
which like I only know so I saw that and
I I don't have the discipline to keep
fat that low that long like I like
having fat in my diet but I knew a few
people who were like just legitimately
crazy and had I don't think they derive
any pleasure from food whatsoever so
like these are folks who like one of
them literally all he ate just because
it was convenient for like six months
was peanut butter and whole milk like
that was literally his entire diet and
and the other people were like perfectly
fine being just as restrictive with
their diet just heating for convenience
and so they decided to give that a shot
and their diet basically looked like
protein shakes and breakfast cereal with
skim milk which like that may not sound
that bad but apparently it gets really
terrible really quickly I can eyes and
yeah but yeah so like all four of them
did that and stuck to it pretty strictly
for like I think ten or twelve weeks and
no basically had what you were
describing like they gained quite a bit
of weight and they had they didn't get
like DEXA scans but in the gym where
they trained they had one of like the
four-point BIA scales which isn't great
but is pretty good in me and they put on
I think an average of like twelve or
fifteen pounds and only about three
percent body fat which is pretty good
yeah yeah so you know I'm not at a point
where I'm like ready to make bold
scientific claims based on it so I I
because we would like to discuss science
so much on the podcast I think it's
important that we label our Anna
don't is anecdote but you know I have
noticed with my clients well it's it's
anecdote plus one study that neither of
us read the languages published it
exactly so it it it possibly has some
level of scientific support but we can
neither confirm nor deny that right yeah
but in any case you know like I have
seen with some of my clients that are
interested in basically recompensed Inge
at their current weight but you know
maybe a little reduction of fat maybe a
little gain and muscle we can push
calories pretty high without getting
body weight to budge if we go to a
little bit lower fat higher carb
distribution kind of and I have I have
seen that the bulks tend to be quite
successful when we keep fat either low
to moderate and try to push the carbs as
much as we can
again that's anecdote but when I look at
the science I also think you know what
are the pros and cons of either going
super high fat or super high carb and
when I look at the the pros of shifting
toward a general higher reliance on
carbohydrate in the diet I'm seeing you
know I'm seeing a solid boost in
strength endurance potentially I see
greater reassurance that were
effectively replenishing glycogen you
know day in and day out
I see potentially increases in total
daily energy expenditure that might
allow us to have a little bit more food
to play around with so generally
speaking like I said you can be very
successful whether you're going high fat
or high carb as long as all the other
pieces are in place I have a slight
preference to lean toward us you know a
higher carbon taking a lower fat intake
but but I don't want that to be
misinterpreted you can have absolutely
fantastic results whichever route you go
when we talk about these potential
benefits of going toward a higher carb
lower fat intake again its anecdote and
we're talking about what I would
characterize us pretty pretty slim
differences you know it's it's not like
if you go low fat high carb it's like oh
wow now I can
400 more calories a day and we're
talking about you know very very modest
effects when it comes to their magnitude
but when I get people in who really want
to push it and want to try to optimize
things to that you know 100% efficiency
level when it comes to their approach I
do try to kind of nudge them toward
higher carb lower fat okay we got a
question for Gregg here the question is
from Michael the question is how
important is delayed onset muscle
soreness
I've been powerlifting for a little over
18 months and so far I haven't had any
significant amount of soreness my
program has reasonably high volume and
intensity so basically the question is
is that problematic that he hasn't run
into any delayed onset muscle soreness
would you mind reading the end of that
question just so a we can get it on the
record but be it's your words not mine
so okay here we go Michael he said kind
regards from Germany PS the Netherlands
must be destroyed I just want to jump
out it's like when you're a politician
and someone at your rally gets a little
bit carried away and you got to grab the
mic and say hey now let's let's not go
overboard the Netherlands should not be
destroyed they should be beaten into
submission and turned into a vassal
state no no Greg just relax
you should we should encourage people to
say snarky things about the Netherlands
and I think that is a sufficient
punishment for what they've done we can
agree to disagree okay
would you care to talk about delayed
onset muscle soreness sure um so yeah I
think so don't let me start by saying
delayed onset muscle soreness is
probably to some degree a proxy for
whether or not training was hard enough
to be effective but is also a really bad
proxy so essentially I think like if
you're training and you're making
progress you're getting bigger you're
getting stronger I don't care if you're
getting sore or not if
so this kind of cuts both ways so some
people are like oh man I'm still getting
super sore from my workouts like is that
a bad thing if you're making progress
like if your your objectively gaining
muscle and getting stronger it's not a
bad thing that you're still getting sore
and vice-versa
if you're building muscle getting
stronger and you're not sore it's not a
bad thing that you're not getting sore
so like getting some degree of sore from
training is probably to some degree
correlated with the effectiveness of
your training but it would be a very
very weak correlation so I think more
like if if you're training you're not
getting sore and you're also not making
progress I think that lack of soreness
may be a somewhat decent indication that
maybe you should be training a little
bit harder but I think like other just
like subjective assessments of you know
I feel good all the time I'm sleeping
well I'm showing no no overt signs of
overreaching or overtraining and I'm not
making progress and I'm not getting sore
kind of putting that whole picture
together probably gives you like the
overall takeaway that
hey I'm probably not training hard
enough to be making progress
maybe volume needs to go up maybe I need
to push a little bit closer to failure
maybe maybe I need to choose more
challenging exercises with a longer
range of motion which like longer ranges
of motion are generally associated with
a little bit more soreness so like you
know if if you have that whole picture
not making progress feeling fresh all
the time and not sore then yeah maybe
that's indicative of something is going
bad insofar as you're not training hard
enough but if everything in the gym is
going good and you're making gains
the fact that you're not sore is great
like I don't think people want to
necessarily walk around being crazy sore
all the time for its own sake
so I mean I I and I've seen it I've seen
very different responses from the
people so like some folks legitimately
like you know get a couple weeks of
training under their belt they build up
some like repeated bout effect type
adaptations to protect them from muscle
damage and then they make great progress
and they're just never sore from
training and that's cool and then other
people they do you know they're not as
sore three months into training as they
were three days into training but they
do still get pretty sore after most of
their workouts but they still make good
progress and that's also cool so so I do
think that there's probably some like
innate characteristic that determines
whether you maintain a significant level
of ongoing soreness as you continue
training and I do think that does differ
quite a bit between people but I mean
ultimately the question is are you
making progress or not not are you
getting sore or not that makes sense all
right next question for Eric is from
Dmitri so Erik what are your thoughts on
sodium intake for lifters rather or
whether in absolute terms or relative to
potassium intake honestly I feel a
little bit bad for sodium I feel like
sodium's had a hook a tough go of it in
the last 20-30 years or so but luckily
there's some newer research that has
really helped really helped elucidate
exactly what sodium does or does not do
in the diet so when you talk about
sodium generally speaking people are
worried about you know a high sodium
diet and the relationship it has to
things like blood pressure and heart
disease and the relation to heart
disease is essentially through its
effects on blood pressure so the general
concept that that's been popularized for
a long time is you eat a lot of sodium
your blood pressure goes up you become
hypertensive and that is a problem now
what's really cool is that there's been
more recent research I believe one of
the prominent researchers in this area
is Robin Felder or Fed l'heure
at the University of Virginia and what
they've looked at is something called
salt sensitivity and they've looked at
you know in the population isn't
necessarily true that everyone has a
blood pressure increase in response to
increasing their dietary sodium intake
and what they found is the answer's no
but more surprising the answer is really
not even close if you look at their
estimates of the you know the general
population
what they find is they estimate that
about 25 to 30 percent of the population
is what they call salt sensitive and
that's kind of a classical understanding
you go on a high sodium diet your blood
pressure goes up you're hypertensive
that's a problem now what they found is
that a large percent of the population
their their blood pressure really isn't
particularly sensitive to any kind of
deviation of salt in the diet whether
it's going up a little or down a little
and they also found probably even more
surprisingly that somewhere between
probably five and fifteen percent of the
population is what you could call
inverse salt sensitive so if you do an
intervention to reduce their sodium
intake in the diet their blood pressure
actually goes up oh that's wild I did
not knew that yeah so so I mean I I
certainly don't claim to be a sodium
expert or a hypertension expert but
there is some very interesting stuff out
there when it comes to individual
responses now you might wonder why why
there's still all these government
guidelines that say like hey limit your
sodium and that's because if you look at
the the number of people you know
hypertension is very common and if you
look at the population of people who are
hypertensive a huge percentage of them
are gonna see a benefit from reducing
their sodium intake so that's why you
still see these blanket statements that
say basically the null hypothesis all
else being equal is you're probably
going to be just fine if you keep your
sodium within kind of a lower range you
know it's a small percentage of the
population that's in verse salt
sensitive this is kind of a newer thing
the first I've seen up it was like in
2013 I'm not sure if if there's a war
going on in the sodium research about
whether or not this is legit but
generally it's it seems that they've
made a pretty strong case for it but but
the reason that you see that that
general recommendation like I said the
percentage of people among hypertensives
that are salt sensitive is substantially
above 30 so it still makes sense to
generally tell people hey keep your
sodium not you know like 2-0 but keep it
within this working range and I mean
also like messaging for public health
stuff has to be pretty simplistic and
straightforward yeah cuz the the former
food pyramid and now like the MyPlate
dietary guidelines are super simple and
straightforward and still like no one
follows them yeah so if you made it even
more complicated and you're like alright
so for three months do your sodium
levels like this monitor blood pressure
for another three months put it in this
range monitor blood pressure for another
three months go really high sodium and
monitor blood pressure and then you know
like plug that all in Excel do a do a
regression to see like blood pressure
and how that's related to various sodium
intakes for yourself and then from that
you can personalize your sodium intake
people are gonna [ __ ] do that like
people in our audience might do that but
like ninety nine point eight percent of
the general population you're not gonna
do that at all like you you you have to
in I think like Public Health
recommendations and especially Public
Health dietary recommendations catch a
lot of flack from like the quote unquote
evidence-based fitness industry for that
reason like this
they're coming at it they're looking at
it the same way a physiologist would not
like a public health person would and
until you've like talked to someone
who's a dietician who works with
clinical populations and asked them like
what general level of complexity of
recommendations do people actually stick
with and they'll tell you like
it's the most basic [ __ ] and if you try
to make it complicated it's not gonna
stick they're not going to do it so I
mean like the that the type of dietary
advice that the government can give the
entire population is fundamentally
different than the type of dietary
advice you can give to serious body
builders who are going to you know try
to dial in everything possible about
their nutrition like it's it's it's two
completely different games definitely
yeah so when you look at like what are
the recommended intakes for sodium they
generally tell you to keep sodium at or
below like 2300 milligrams a day and
they also tell you to keep potassium and
the like 3500 to 4700 milligram per day
range now I I tried to when it comes to
nutrition I try to make things simple
until they need to get complicated if
that makes sense so I try to start big
picture and then as barriers and
challenges arise then I troubleshoot him
generally speaking I think the the most
simplistic recommendation be had just
shoot for the recommended ranges problem
solved but realistically that most
people get way more sodium than that as
the question alluded to I think it was
in the question there is some degree of
you know sodium and potassium exist in
this balance in the body you know they
do have in many cases opposing roles
there are a lot of physiological
processes that involve opposing
co-transport of sodium and potassium so
the two are intrinsically linked and
theoretically the kidney should be
responsible for sorting a lot of that
out and making sure that both sodium and
potassium levels are maintained within a
reasonably appropriate range so
generally speaking you know the easiest
recommendation and again I'm not a
dietitian so this is just my my
perspective of what I've seen in the
research and what I've seen just as a
human who knows how much sodium the
potassium they eat but generally
speaking it's like hey if you can
for the recommended recommended intakes
great if not keep an eye on your blood
pressure if your blood pressure becomes
a problem then usually the first line of
defense that you're gonna see is they
will tell you to simultaneously well
first I'll try to get an idea of your
intakes but in a lot of cases they'll
say lower your sodium intake and/or
increase your potassium intake and it's
it's not atypical to see people with
mild hypertension I'm pretty sure it's
not atypical to see them give a
recommendation not only to reduce sodium
but also to increase potassium obviously
potassium I feel compelled to say this
don't like go nuts and take like a ton
of potassium supplements because
excessive potassium is remarkably
dangerous so I'm pretty sure that
there's got to be some kind of legal
limit if you ever look at potassium
supplements pretty much all of them go
up to 99 milligrams exactly yeah I think
there's got to be some kind of legal
limit where they like won't let you do
more than that that wouldn't surprise me
but in any case yeah so you don't want
to with sodium and potassium the only
way to really regret things is to try to
get really cute with it like you'll see
bodybuilders who put themselves in a
really dangerous spot when before
competitions that they try to get really
fancy with loading this and depleting
that with sodium and potassium I would
say try to aim for sensible intakes of
both if you start to run into blood
pressure issues you know that there's
usually a multi-pronged approach which
is try to achieve you know a BMI that's
more consistent with good cardio
metabolic health you know if you're a
high level strength athlete that might
not be something you're willing to do
you know what I mean like I get it
there's not a lot of strong men out
there that are doing well
internationally with a BMI of 22 so I
get it that might be off the table but
you know enhancing cardiovascular
fitness reducing sodium increasing
potassium those seem to be generally
what goes what goes on when you run into
hypertension issues again I'm not a
medical doctor I'm not a dietitian so
take that with an enormous grain of salt
yeah so that's pretty much as far as I
go with it just make sure it's not a
problem if it's a problem address it do
the other thing I wanted to mention
sometimes you'll see bodybuilders diets
can get low in sodium late in a prep
just because you you kind of just stop
eating things it's like all of a sudden
you look at you're like oh I don't need
any sodium because all the foods that I
used to eat with calories were where I
got my sodium and so sometimes the body
builders you see that they they really
struggle to get a pump late in prep for
many reasons but one contributing factor
among many could be super low sodium
intakes so I have known some
bodybuilders that laid in a prep they'll
actually try to put a little additional
sodium in the pre-workout meal to
facilitate that but that's about as
interesting as I hope to be with sodium
and potassium basically just don't don't
do anything crazy and if you start
running into blood pressure issues
issues do understand that sodium and
potassium can both be implicated there
so I just want to throw this out there I
think you answered the explicit question
Dimitri asked but I don't think you
actually answered the question that
Dimitri had in mind if my assumptions
are correct okay so there is a there is
a current in like the like non-academic
bodybuilding nutrition world saying like
hyper loading sodium can be beneficial
for either performance her body comp it
wouldn't shock me if that's what Dimitri
had in mind when he asked this question
so do are are you aware of any direct
research or perhaps plausible mechanisms
by which like substantially higher than
recommended levels of sodium intake
could be beneficial I'm not aware of it
but here's what I would say if you look
at the sodium bicarbonate literature I
can't imagine anybody's loading higher
sodium intakes than that unless unless
incorrect yeah that those are that
wouldn't surprise me those but so the
sodium bicarbonate literature features
some pretty high sodium intakes as part
of the sodium bicarbonate and the
bicarbonate literature is positive but
not remarkably so and any benefit you
two tribute to sodium would have to be
on top of the benefit you're attributing
to bicarbonate and I would I think the
mechanistically it makes a lot more
sense to assume that bicarbonate is is
pushing the majority of that benefit I
think that no I mean I I air to conclude
Gris I don't so I don't think there's
anything magical about high sodium
intake I just wanted to get your take on
that because because I think that's
probably what Dmitri had in mind
yeah I'm not aware of that but I
initially action is skepticism largely
based on on what I've mentioned with the
sodium but you'd think bicarb probably
works and if sodium was also driving
significant effects you'd probably
expect that to be that bicarbonate
literature to be markedly more
impressive than it is know in motion
another so when I usually see it it's
because bodybuilders when they when they
worry about high sodium it's because
they are on like an if it fits your
macros type approach to dieting which
has no limitation on sodium it built
into their baked into the cake so to
speak so people often go for these
really good tasting things that fit
their macros and you do tend to find
that there are fairly high sodium
intakes so if you were to go to any
bodybuilder who's in a caloric surplus
who's doing like an if it fits your
macros it's not uncommon to see people
that are taking in seven thousand eight
thousand milligrams of sodium a day and
usually people when they finally look
into it and find their sodium intake
they go oh god I'm eating three times
the amount I should and usually what you
find with them is they have very healthy
body composition they also have plenty
of potassium in the diet you find that
their blood pressure is remarkably
normal and you're like it's probably
fine yes oh that that's the context I
typically see it in but I didn't even
know that people were we're out there
drinking salt water to to get huge yeah
it was it was a thing on tea nation
three years ago and I could be wrong
about this so if I am like don't don't
crucify me on Twitter Instagram but I
think that that's I think that that's
part of the vertical diet as well
interesting I mean I will say so
certainly you electrolytes are
critically important you want to make
sure that you're getting adequate
intakes of sodium and potassium to keep
the old body functioning but I struggle
to see a plausible mechanism by which
that would be particularly orga genic
fair enough if I'm wrong someone out
there I'm sure will correct me
aggressively alright great we got a
question for you here from McKechnie
Angus probably Angus McKechnie maybe I
don't know maybe hoppy even tasted it
well there you go
how important is it for trainees to
experiment with different training
styles to see what methods may work best
for them how would you recommend
organizing experimental period of
training to see if for example you
respond better to speed or power
training and what should be measured
benchmarked against so that's a good
question uh and I think it is critically
important one of the one of the pitfalls
that I see a lot of lifters and
particularly new lifters falling into is
like the Internet has flavor of the week
workouts but it's more like flavor of
the two or three years type styles of
training so you know like back in the
day let's say eight or nine years ago if
you were an intermediate lifter everyone
would say like do Texas method and then
it became 531
and then for a while the cube method got
super popular and then it was like five
three one again and now I don't even
know I don't really pay attention to
that chatter all that much but but
basically like there there is kind of
like a fitness community hivemind
about what the best style of training
for lifters of a particular like
strength categorization are and and
generally those are you know sane and
typically effective programs and so it's
it's not bad that they're being
recommended to a lot of people but the
the pitfall you can fall into is like
something that works well for most
people very well may not work well for
you and something that I see a lot is
people look at what is written about
particular programs on the internet they
take it at face value they say like man
if this is the bee's knees it must be
the best thing out there so I'm gonna do
it and then they try it and it doesn't
work well for them and the conclusion
they come away with is like man I just
suck I can't make any progress something
is wrong with me because obviously this
program is fantastic versus you know
thinking oh maybe this is a good general
program but it's just not great for me
and there is I've talked about this on
the podcast before but there is some
research not particularly strong
research but some research
one study by beavin at all and another
by Jones and colleagues basically
testing groups of people on different
training programs and and just seeing
like using crossover designs checking
and seeing like you know do some people
just respond to one style of training
better than others and it very much
seems that they do and so like I think
that an important step in your training
journey is trying to find the style of
training that does work best for you and
and the stuff that works well for a
large number of people probably on
average will work for you as well but it
may not necessarily so I think some
degree of troubleshooting is
important to do so then the question is
like how best to do that and I think
that the I think that there are two
approaches you can take
and I used to favor the first approach
and now I am more favored the second
approach so the first approach would
basically just be like to try to find
like three or four training programs
that represent different broad
archetypes of training so for like
submaximal high-volume type stuff you
might go Shaco for like lower frequency
generally lower volume type stuff even
though it kind of depends what version
you do you might go like five three one
whatever like there's there's a lot of
popular programs out there whose nuts
and bolts are different so you could
just pick like three or four of them and
say like hey these are programs that
come highly recommended on paper they
look considerably different I'm gonna
try each one out for 12 weeks see which
one I have the best gains from and then
say like okay this seems to be the style
of training I do best with so I'm gonna
use this program as kind of like my base
training style you know just run it
until it stops working and then make
small iterations on it from there to
keep making progress that's what I used
to recommend but one I don't think
anyone actually does that because if
you're doing if you're doing for
programs for like 12 weeks apiece with
the assumption that one of them is going
to do best for you then you're kind of
going into that essentially year of
experimentation with the assumption of
I'm going to be doing nine months of
suboptimal training and I don't think
people like that and then another thing
you can run into is there can be like
some path dependency going on so for
example let's say you do a Shaco program
in like I don't know for sure but I
think this has happened to me before
so like let's say you do a Shaco program
you make some gains from it but not like
i popping other
early gains and then you do maybe like a
lower volume higher intensity program
and make really really awesome gains
really quickly then can you necessarily
conclude that like oh that second
program is way better for me than Shaco
or you know is it possible that doing
that Shaco training you know did help
you make progress but also build a
really really awesome base of work
capacity that lets you then like benefit
more from the like next higher intensity
style of training you did so it's not
you're not necessarily isolating all
relevant variables when you do a test
like that
so the second approach you could use
which is the one that I favor more now
is just hopping on a program and riding
it until it stops working and then
trying something else and riding that
till it stops working and then trying
something else and riding that until it
stops working and by riding it till it
stops working I mean like legitimately
give it a good faith effort to make
tweaks and troubleshoot and whatnot and
you know the first program or two you
try you may be eking gains out of that
for like a solid two years before you
Plateau and it's like okay this
legitimately doesn't seem to be working
for me anymore and then you can just
move on to something else
ultimately now I think the the baseline
that makes the most sense like the the
comparator or that you should be the
most concerned about is just how strong
was I a month or two ago and if whatever
you're doing now is allowing you to make
progress you can't know for sure that it
is the optimal training style for you
but it is good enough to make gains and
that is a blessed thing because if
you're making pretty continuous progress
for five years straight you're gonna be
pretty big and pretty strong by the end
of that process so as long as you're
doing something currently that's letting
you make gains that's awesome
once something kind of Peters out for
you you know don't just throw the baby
out with the bathwater
trying to make some tweaks within the
overall framework of that program to try
to make it work for you again once it
does just stop working then don't
maintain like an emotional connection to
it at that point cut bait try something
very different maybe that's gonna work
for you maybe it won't maybe try
something very different and it doesn't
do [ __ ] for you then you know after
eight weeks or so and it's like okay
this clearly isn't doing anything cut
bait move on to something else
so essentially like plateauing hard is
your trigger to let's try something very
different so anyway that's that's how I
would recommend doing it these days and
and ultimately you can't know for sure
like basically you can never know for
sure that you have hit the optimal style
of training for yourself that is that is
an unknowable question but what you can
know is am I making progress or not and
so you use that to guide things as long
as something's allowing you to make
progress you stick with it once it stops
allowing you to make progress you know
it's like the quote the definition of
insanity is trying things again and
again and expecting a different result
once it's clear that something has
stopped working for you you know then
try something substantially different
and if that's working for you stick with
that until it stops so so I think that's
how you would recommend approach
recommend approaching it these days
that's a good point you bring up about
not wondering if this is the you know
the most optimal thing you could
possibly doing at this possibly be doing
at this moment but just like if it's
really not right for you you're gonna
figure that out yes it's not gonna take
a long time yeah I mean even if even if
progress is quite slow so let's say
you're putting five pounds on a lift
every two months at that point you're
putting thirty pounds on that lift in a
year assuming you don't start you know
incredibly weak so you know let's take
the squat for example let's say you
start training
you know you do some sort of like linear
progression that spits you out with like
a 300-pound squat which you know seems
to be somewhat typical for your first
few months of training and then let's
say for the next five years you know
you're making pretty slow but steady
progress and you're putting five pounds
on your squat every two months that's 30
pounds a year
that's 150 pounds in five years that's a
450 squat at that point like you're a
fairly strong person at no point in that
process was anything super exciting like
you weren't you know setting the world
on fire but like you look back and it's
like oh I have a lot to show for these
last five years of training if it's any
slower than like five pounds per two
months I would kind of consider that a
plateau like you're unless you're
already like a super advanced lifter
you're at that point you're not really
making strength gains fast enough that
that I would consider you really going
anywhere but yeah even it like five
pounds per two months that gets you
somewhere over time so yeah I mean
progress is a beautiful thing
progress plus time gets you somewhere I
mean that's that's ultimately the name
of the game for everyone so I don't
think I don't think you should program
hop and get greedy because you're making
progress but it's not quite as fast as
you would like because that progress is
gonna add up but at the same time I
don't think you should get too married
to a particular style of training that
you stick with it for you know months
and years after it stops producing
results for you I agree all right
question for Eric from laws this is the
point that our audience is probably
gonna tune out but whatever we are we're
brave we are the fitness podcast going
where no one else's dares to and we
actually mean it this time
yeah so from laws do you think that
Bayesian statistics will be used in
future studies for analysis
okay I intentionally hid this one at
this part of the the program here
because if you're still around you're a
nerd whether you know it or not now you
know if you're if you're an hour
forty-five minutes into this thing
you're a nerd so you might like this I'm
gonna keep this very brief and I know
that everyone's gonna hate my answer
because when you answer a question like
this the statistical purists hate you
for simplifying and the people that
aren't into statistics hate you for
talking about abstract things
okay so everyone's gonna hate this I'm
gonna make it brief let's dive in they
asked if we think Bayesian statistics
are gonna essentially become more
prevalent but that's compared to what
that's compared to the current stats
paradigm that we basically all use in
sports science which is frequentist
statistics okay so with frequentist
stats like when you read a study and
says hey here's this thing we did an
anova here's the p-value what you're
doing with that general broad family of
statistics is you're trying to find the
probability of the data given a
hypothesis so what that means is we're
going to assume like let's say we're
looking at creatine and we're doing a
t-test where the post-test value is
higher than pre you're starting with the
null hypothesis that you are assuming to
be true which is that this creatine does
not make you stronger and then what
you're going to do is calculate a
p-value and the p-value represents the
probably of obtaining the observed data
that you collected or more extreme data
given the assumption that we know that
creatine doesn't work that's what you're
that's the assumption you're starting
with so if your p-value is really low
that means that if we assume this
treatment doesn't work there's a very
low chance that we would find in effect
this large associated with the treatment
right so then you'd say okay well we're
gonna reject that hypothesis and we're
gonna say the creatine actually did work
that that's basically the simplified
approach of what frequentist stats are
but but actually it's more like we're
saying it didn't not work exactly yeah
so
frequent to stats are weird they're very
weird and that's that actually is a
great segue into the Bayesian stuff
because people who like Bayesian stats
are like the only way to make frequent
to stuff sound like it makes sense is to
oversimplify to a point of no longer
being accurate but that's generally the
framework we currently use we assume the
treatment doesn't work we find a low
p-value and say well if the treatment
doesn't work pretty weird that we found
you know such an impressive effect and
then we kind of imply it looks like the
treatment does work now Bayesian stats
flipped the whole thing on its head so a
Bayesian approach generally again this
is very simplified is looking at the
probability of a hypothesis given the
data so another way to frame that is you
know after you collect the data the
question of a Bayesian approach is which
hypothesis is better supported by the
data again it's simplified but a common
application that we have seen in some
exercise science papers already is the
Bayes factor and so if you look at like
the bf 10 which is one of the ways you
can present a Bayes factor it's
basically the ratio of the predictive
performance of two different competing
hypotheses so let's make that tangible
the competing hypotheses are the
treatment works or the treatment doesn't
work if you get a bf ten of four then
you could say you know the
interpretation would be that these data
are four times more likely to occur
under the hypothesis that the treatment
did work versus the treatment that it
doesn't okay so basically it's inverting
the question instead of saying what are
the probability of getting these data
assuming a certain hypothesis the
Bayesian approach is after we collect
the data which hypothesis do we seem to
support more and really that's the
question we're always asking in these
studies is did it work or not work which
hypothesis do the data most closely
support and so then the question I think
a very fair question would be why don't
we all do Bayesian statistics always I
don't really know the answer to that and
usually we
do your first like I have no expertise
in Bayesian stats I've actually never
used them in a paper cuz it's it's this
kind of thing that's just slowly
trickling its way into this area but my
guesses of why it's not more common
I believe it requires some more
intensive calculations and computation
that what you find in the history of
stats is everybody awake the history of
stats is where you lose everybody very
brief statement a lot of times we
discover the theory before we have the
ability to compute it if you look back
into like a lot of the innovations
happening in the 40s 50s 60s in
statistics it's like we understand the
theory and we know how you could compute
it but realistically who has access to
that computational power yeah but now
that you know every phone is like you
know it don't they say like your phone
has way more computing power than like
the first mission of the moon
oh the so the this is an actual fact the
total amount of computational power in
like Mission Control in Houston for the
first trip to the moon was very
comparable to that of a Game Boy Color
Game Boy colors were cool okay so so I
think that might have something to do
with it I also think people are
uncomfortable with the the idea there is
an aspect of Bayesian stats you have to
specify a prior distribution I don't
want to get into the details on that no
one wants to hear it but it does
introduce theoretically a level of
subjectivity that I think some people
are a little bit uncomfortable with you
should be able to justify any decision
you make regarding the priors so I don't
think it's like an airtight
justification to throw out Bayesian
stats based on that I mean or if you're
coming from a frequentist background you
can just start with a minimally
informative prior and it's essentially
like a null
right yeah so I think those are two
things that have caused people to drag
their feet a little bit in the you know
the timeline of starting to embrace
Bayesian stats if you read exercise
science you've probably seen something
called magnitude based inferences one
other thing I would
there is like most people who aren't
statisticians don't particularly like
learning about stats and so I think a
lot of people just kind of go with
whatever stats they were taught when
they were in grad school for so like I
don't think there are any exercise
science grad programs teaching Bayesian
statistics to like their master students
and so I mean some people might go get
Bayesian stats
training when they get to a ph.d program
or they may just be super into stats and
like once they get out and they're doing
research on their own they're like oh
this seems cool I'm gonna learn more
about it but I I think there's some
level of inertia because it's not it's
not part of the statistical toolkit that
people are imparted during their
graduate education and for the most part
like physiologists are gonna be
interested in like you know techniques
to study physiology not necessarily
techniques to do statistics so it's just
not a common piece of continuing
education that a lot of scientists in
our field are going to gravitate towards
yeah I actually wanted to take a course
in Bayesian stats in the bio stats
department at UNC during my PhD and my
stat professor at the time was like dude
that class is very specifically for
people who in about a year are gonna
have a PhD in bio stats you don't want
to put yourself through that he was like
that is gonna be not user-friendly at
all and you're gonna hate your life
every day you're in there I don't think
okay I'll learn it later really brief
thing I want to touch base on people
have probably seen magnitude based
inferences and papers if you've ever
seen a paper where the outcome instead
of a p-value if they just said like this
was probably beneficial or possibly
trivial or likely harmful or something
like that
that's probably coming from a magnitude
based inferences framework you're
probably gonna see a lot less of it in
the future
god I hope yes so some statisticians
heard about it and and they wrote at
least a couple papers I think basically
saying magnitude based inferences the
Spirit is good what they're trying to
get at but computationally there are
some issues
and it is not actually a Bayesian
analysis it's just a frequentist
analysis that has assumed some Bayesian
ish interpretations and so you know the
statisticians I think that the lead
author who's done a lot of this stuff is
Kristen sign on e and she's made some
very convincing arguments that seem to
be pretty airtight III don't think that
you know MBI like I said the spirit of
it is good I don't think it's the worst
thing in the world when we when we look
at a field with a lot of underpowered
studies but the question is what are you
doing with the inferences and if you're
holding them on the same level of rigor
as like a more formal statistical test
that's a problem yeah I think it's
objectively it's safe to say that that
that's problematic but when we're
looking at these small studies about
what increases a bench press more the
idea of using those interpretations of
magnitude based inferences to get some
clues from your data to spur some you
know inform how you're training athletes
or something and you know we're not
talking about biomedical life-and-death
situations here I don't think it's the
worst thing in the world to say like
okay there might have been a slight
little benefit there the question is
just how how literally are you
interpreting those outcomes and if it's
extremely literal and you're giving the
procedure more mathematical credit than
is due you're probably making a mistake
so we've talked about what Bayesian
statistics are we talked about how they
differ from the more common frequentist
statistics some benefits to a Bayesian
approach some barriers that have gotten
in the way of Bayesian statistics
becoming more popular within our field
but ultimately the question was do we
expect to see more of them in the future
I would say the answer is yes I expect
because it we've essentially seen almost
none to date so I do expect we'll start
to see more of it in the future but the
question I can't answer is whether or
not it will really catch on and become a
a rivaling kind of approach to the
extent that you know a large percentage
of papers now
opt to use Bayesian stats rather than
frequentist approaches I don't know if
the field will get to that point where
it becomes a really prevalent thing as
Greg mentioned it we're gonna have to as
a field start to really embrace it
collectively there's that inertia where
because it's not what's currently done
there's a bit of an uphill battle in
terms of making it more accepted in
common it's going to take a lot of
effort from people within the field to
go outside of their comfort zone and
devote a lot of time and effort into
learning it and learning how to how to
do it how to interpret it and how to
apply it
I do think generally speaking it would
be nice to see more of it but whether or
not that will come to fruition
ultimately time will tell that that's
all we need to say right I think so yeah
okay good last question in the day for
whoever is still listening this is a
really good one so last question we like
to do things that are either like very
nitty gritty research related or kind of
relate to the profession like the
industry kind of so this is one that
kind of relates to people who want to
get into the industry I think as someone
who went the standard business route
after college and is getting minimal
satisfaction from their career how
possible is it to get proper
certifications for nutrition and
training to make a career out of
something I'm more passionate about so
basically from someone who doesn't come
from an academic background in the field
can you get there and enter the
profession using certifications and
other educational tools yeah so there's
there's two answers to this question
there's there's an answer to the
explicit question being asked and then
there's an answer to what seems to be
the implicit question under the surface
so the explicit question is how possible
is it to get the proper certifications
to make a career out of it and it's
incredibly possible to do that
many days you got yeah if if if you have
a long weekend and are pretty decent and
like reading and focusing on stuff you
can probably do the study required to
pass most personal training
certification and courses like the vast
majority are online they're like
somewhat pricey but not incredibly
expensive to take so like sitting for a
test is probably gonna set you back I
don't know
300 bucks give or take I would guess
which you know it's not nothing but
that's probably an amount of money you
can put up if you currently have a
full-time job and yeah I mean like you
get the study materials you study for a
week or maybe two or like I said like a
long weekend if you're if you really
want to get after it and you'll be fine
so yeah it's incredibly easy to get
those certifications the question then
is once you have those certifications
how easy is it to make a career out of
it
and that's probably going to be quite a
bit more challenging so a couple things
to note the last time I looked at the
data and this may be slightly out of
date but it's probably somewhat close to
accurate is the average yearly total
compensation for personal trainers in
the US is somewhere around seventeen
thousand dollars a year so you're
probably not gonna be making Bank off of
it at least to start with and also
burnout rates are really really high I
don't remember those statistics off the
top of my head but I want to say like
something like eighty percent of
personal trainers don't make it past
three years so it's do you know if that
income value does that include people
who if they have like a client here or
there aside from their normal like
steady job mm-hmm I think that's
everyone so it may include those folks
but one thing to note as well as like
I mean most people who do it full-time
are aren't rolling in it
we're either yeah yeah because like if
you're doing it full-time
for at least a few months your income is
probably gonna be virtually nil so it's
gonna depend whether you're working at
like a private facility as like a coach
who is maybe paid hourly doing group
training versus if you're like at a big
box gym and you're like it's your job to
get personal training clients for
yourself so it's going to be a lot
easier to make a good living from it if
you have good sales skills like
especially like in-person training in
big box gyms making a good living from
it is like 30 percent how good you are
at training people because that's gonna
affect retention and like 70 percent
sales skills and people skills because
the people skills are gonna go a lot
further
as far as retention goes and is gonna
have a tremendous amount to do with like
can you actually get to a full client
load see yeah it's it's not hard to get
the proper letters behind your name to
get your foot in the door it's quite a
bit harder to actually make a good
career out of it yeah I mean one thing
to highlight you know there there are
some some personal training related
certifications that are pretty rigorous
that that like will push you
academically and and you know it I don't
want people to hear that and assume it
applies to all certifications when we
say like all you could do in a weekend
you know the fact that there are some
remarkably easy ones out there I don't
want people to think that we're saying
like oh your certification is is trash
yeah yeah you know for sure there are
quite a few that require a great deal of
effort and studying so no I'm just
saying that for the vast majority of
cases those are like this specialty
certifications not just like the you
know baby's first personal trainer cert
certification yeah but in any case yeah
I mean like you said it's the barrier to
obtaining some like any type of
certification in the in the field that
barrier is quite low especially when it
gets to some of
kind of lower-tier personal training
certifications that are out there but
yeah turning it into a career that
that's where there's a lot more like you
said personal skills a lot more sweat
involved of of really making it happen
and it's a competitive space so for
people who are getting into it
I would suggest a good way to set
yourself apart is you know not to say
like well I got the certification so you
know the learning sides done now let's
now let's chat people up and see if we
can turn that into sales you know the
more that you can continue your
education the thing that is so important
is reminding yourself that you know a
key part of making this work is to be
really damn good at what you do and put
put the effort in into continually
growing in your skill set so that you're
actually bringing results to people I
think that goes a really long way no I
agree one of the one of the things that
makes this particular case hard of you
know you already have a full time job
and you're thinking about transitioning
into being a trainer is like the so one
of the first things I'd recommend to
someone who's like fresh out of school
and they're like I want to be a personal
trainer is I would recommend going and
trying to get like a mentorship with
someone who's already really really good
at what they do
we're like maybe you're not going to be
paid at all
maybe you're just gonna be paid peanuts
but essentially you're working in this
facility you're shadowing the person
you're seeing how they do things because
like the gap between you know what you
learn about writing training programs in
a personal trainer certification and the
actual skills of training people and
being good at that and getting results
like there's a very big gap there and so
like one of the things that's gonna help
the most is like learning firsthand in
person from someone who has years of
experience doing at it and is doing that
and is legitimately good at their craft
but you know if you currently have a job
you probably you're probably accustomed
to
lifestyle that is better and more
expensive than someone who's just
graduating college you know and so like
most people aren't going to want to
massively downgrade their life or go
into a tremendous amount of debt to
shadow a really good trainer for three
or six months to start picking up on
some of those like softer skills of
training so yeah it's one of those
things where you can learn on the job in
like a self-directed way of like okay
I'm a trainer now I need to get clients
I need to you know make money to keep a
roof over my head but you don't actually
have skills training people you're
probably gonna be pretty bad at first
and like just you know just monitoring
yourself and being your own harshest
critic can help you improve pretty
quickly but probably not as quickly as
like actually learning from someone
firsthand so it makes this particular
situation more challenging definitely I
think that does it for this Q&A episode
as always thank you for listening and if
you want one of your questions answered
on a future Q&A episode if you have some
more nitty-gritty questions about
Bayesian statistics and how to identify
your prior distributions you can send
those to what's the URL tiny dot cc /
SBS QA an all lowercase way perfect yeah
and you will find that link in the
episode description as well take care
we'll see you next week thanks for
listening to the stronger by science
podcast now Greg and I are not experts
in medicine or health or really anything
else for that matter so before you make
any changes to your diet and exercise
habits make sure you check with a doctor
or another health care professional if
you enjoyed this podcast and you'd like
to support it
visit stronger by science com2 check out
the products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you